hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the new season of dauntless has begun
the ninjas have left the hidden blade
are back in hiding for now is the time
of fortune and glory the Corsairs
have landed new hunt pass new cosmetics
new mods new modes there's so much new
content that we need to talk about it so
i've teamed up with the masterminds
behind dauntless phoenix loves to tell
you everything you need to know about
the fortune and glory update chart your
course up through the ranks as you
battle to become the best of the best if
you don't know what dauntless is then
get your butts over to play dauntless
calm to download the game for free
whether you play on playstation xbox or
pc if you need more information check
out my create a link in the description
below and for everyone else enough
chitchat if you're ready let's do this
let's start with the hunt pass dauntless
is take on a battle pass the season will
be split into two this time around both
under the heading of high skies the
first section is available right now and
is known as fortune in glory
the second is Zephyr strike which will
follow in August let's not get too far
ahead of ourselves though let's break
down the hunt pass we have right now for
1000 platinum the elite track of the
hunt pass can be unlocked but if you
don't want to commit to the paid version
of the pass the basic track is
completely free to everyone but should
you suddenly feel the urge to buy it
later in the season all rewards are
retroactive meaning if you're on tier 50
of the basic track you'll instantly
unlock everything in the elite version
so don't feel pressured play dauntless
as you see fit of course I couldn't
resist the elite track I'm hooked sorry
in advance for all the pirate puns
incoming straight off the plank we get
our hands on this sexy son of a wench
along the way there are emotes to unlock
such as this drunken fight a knife
juggler and a pirate jig which is
strangely hypnotic we have dyes to
change the color of any of our outfits
and other goodies too like premium
platinum signal flares Gold cars filled
with equipment cells and other treasure
troves in the 50 tiers the weapon
transmog remained the highlight though
but I'll leave you to check them out in
your own time
[Music]
around the town of Ramsgate are now the
skull totems ten can be collected each
day so in reality dropping into
dauntless for a few minutes every day
will level your hunt pass once every two
days so if you're not someone who can
dedicate 40 hours a week to dauntless
progression is still here on top of that
there are weekly bounties which power
level your hunt pass and ask you to try
different weapons and tactics in hunts
it keeps the game feeling fresh if
you've been round the channel before you
know that I love battle passes as a way
to reward players and give them a sense
of accomplishment every day Oh in fact
this is the perfect opportunity for some
self-promotion remember my supporter
creator code works here in dogless too
so if you'd be so kind
keep in mind code a damaru if you ever
purchase something like platinum or
in-game items it helps me out
but no pressure you bu play your way but
anyway the hunt pass is only a small
percentage a tiny part of the fortune
and glory update here in Ramsgate things
have changed the town has evolved and
the new character is waiting to meet us
this is Lady Luck they call me Lady Luck
so how do you like your allah's' Slayer
Lady Luck brings a multitude of content
with her arrival first for the hardcore
players the veterans the players who
live and breathe dauntless an ultimate
challenge has arrived the island of
trials this island isn't like the others
the behemoths here are strong and unlike
anything you've bought before the island
of trials prepare to face the toughest
most unexpected behemoths you've ever
seen put bluntly this is endgame content
for the players who have maxed out their
mastery completed all the exotic quest
lines and have learned how each behemoth
pacts this is father dedicated each week
a behemoth waits borås in a specially
created island biome to face off with
Slayers alone or in squads
this can be match made or you can make
your own groups but these aren't your
typical beasts these matches have
specially curated modifiers which will
force the greatest Slayers to rethink
their approach so admittedly I'm a
part-time Slayer
a weekend Slayer if you will I'm happy
with my progression I've got my armor
and weaponry up to about 500 so I jumped
in and died in less than 30 seconds
all right don't judge me I realize the
importance of those modifiers this week
there is only one self revive we can
only pick our sorry asses up off the
floor once and then have to wait for the
humiliation of another player dragging
you to your feet near site is here too
which prevents the Slayer from seeing
further than a few feet away
it's like glaucoma ask you grandma about
it shielding protects those shocking
quill attacks with well the shield
fortification also adds to this it
protects those shielded quills and give
them more strength and health and then
there's good old electricity you know
because it makes it much easier maybe
not it's insane for a baby Slayer like
me so I went in again and this time I
lasted 1 minute and 42 seconds I'm
improving and on my third attempt we
managed to beat the first behemoth the
challenge was great the accomplishment
felt really awesome but yeah I was flat
on my back when that behemoth died I'm
definitely the MVP here and what does
defeating this trial give us access to
another trial at an even higher level
what it has even more modifiers a larger
health pool and a threat level of 22 ok
so it's going to be a while until I can
fight a threat level 22 behemoth but
maybe you can already but mark my words
I will return for it
quicks the world of course there are far
more rewards for beating this endgame
content we receive a brand new currency
which opens our eyes to a whole new
world of possibilities this is Lady Luck
star she requires the new currency marks
to purchase the goods but these goods
are impressive and offer pros and cons
for example this antique clip decreases
ammo to two rounds but atha charged ammo
is increased by 300% so there's a little
hurdle to this skill a negative and a
positive designed for vets to get the
most out of a certain play style this
may seem out of your reach at the moment
but have it in the back of your mind
that things keep going in the endgame
other things to note in Lady Luck star
are the cosmetics I mean look at this
stored Cloud Strife would be proud of
that one the star will have rotating
stock so if you don't like what you see
come back again later finally to finish
off this new endgame content there's a
real high scoreboard outside a real
in-game scoreboard the wall of Champions
everyone will see your name if you
achieve this perfection but hang on is
that the man the myth the legend Leroy
Jenkins then we usually do
oh my god he just ran in chicken the
trials will reset weekly giving us a
brand new challenge every seven days
threat level 22 I'm coming for you so
that's enough about endgame content
let's quickly go through a few more of
the updates which I think are worth
noticing people on console I know it's
been a little frustrating the
performance issues in Ramsgate but they
have been tweaked and the framerate in
the home hub town have massively
stabilized it's a little thing but it
was much needed and much appreciated the
general star has been updated to with
new pirate themed cosmetics with a few
gaming Easter eggs - look at this one do
a barrel roll GG dauntless GG other
evolutions of dauntless see a halo now
accessible it reminds me of destiny ones
nightfall reward to show how awesome you
were to the rest of the community by the
way a legit followed this guy around
Rams gig to try and get a close-up shot
of that halo I'm sure he thinks he has
an internet stalker now but it's worth
it so thank you very much fellow Slayer
the aggressive fauna we talked about in
the last update should be in the game
but I'm yet to find it it's like a slug
being which can pollute the battlefield
kinda looks like my girlfriend don't
tell her I said that so that's where we
stand anyway remember if you are a ps4
player and have PS Plus you can download
some mighty impressive weapon trans mugs
with a cool blue steel look and twitch
Prime users you can grab the second free
update package which includes loads of
items such as mods collectables and
another piece of that desperado set kind
of Mexican Spanish in look if I see any
dauntless partnerships anywhere else
with other companies I'll be sure to
keep you updated and in the loop oh and
one last thing a new weapon is coming
soon I'm hoping for a sword and shield
but what do you think it will be so
since the launch on ps4 we've had the
heroic winters grave added the hidden
blade hunt pass and now this update
known as fortune and glory don't bless
looks to be in great hands with regular
updates and speaking of updates the next
patch includes sell load outs preset
armor and equipment for quick selection
are on the way to a switch aversion to
hunt on the go
and a mobile phone version in the long
run it's a good time to be a dauntless
player and whether you're a casual once
a week Slayer a three nights a week guy
or a 40-hour a week behemoth dauntless
as you covered thanks for taking the
time to watch this please let me know if
you'd like me to continue with these
update videos I'd love some feedback and
I'll be playing dauntless regardless of
these videos
another huge thank you to Phoenix Labs
for sponsoring this video and letting me
throw out my Creator code to code and
amaru I'm Adam from PlayStation granade
it's been a pleasure if you need a
response from me please tweet me at Adam
grenade it may take me a while but I
will reply to every single person I'll
see you next time I'm going to train for
that dauntless trial threat level 22
this is gonna be a long journey but
worth it see ya
[Music]